josh allen
did the kyle brant tent questions
podcast and there were several different
news items that emerged from there and
one specifically relates to his contract
and the possibility that at some point
josh allen could be subject to the
franchise tag the same way a guy like
dak prescott or kirk cousins was at the
quarterback position here is
the
portion of that podcast from josh allen
regarding his thoughts on the franchise
tag
i love cantaloupe you love will ferrell
how do you feel about the words
franchise tag
the opposite of cantaloupe right yep
exactly and
i don't i don't think it's great for the
team nor the player and uh
again i need to do more research on it
but
if you look at the guys that have been
tagged in the past couple years um you
know as far as the quarterback position
goes dak and kurt cousins and
um
at the end of the day
they can you can make the case that they
should have just done the deal
the year prior or a couple years prior
um so
it is what it is at the end of the day
whatever happens happens and uh you know
it's not gonna deter me from trying to
be like i said the best quarterback for
the bills
he made it clear separately he wants to
be in buffalo for a very long time yeah
connection between josh allen and bill's
fans is extremely strong after what
happened last year when his grandmother
patricia allen died and all the money
that poured in to the children's
hospital in buffalo it was a great story
and i can't imagine him playing for any
team other than the bills but chris
there's a business side to this and josh
said he needs to do more research on it
i actually wrote an item about this
right before the show
he doesn't need to do any research he'd
just watch the show and we'll tell you
how it works it's bad for the player the
first year it's great for the player the
second year it's awesome for the player
the third year because the first year
you assume the injury risk you assume
the ineffectiveness risk that you're
going to go carson wentz all of a sudden
and they're not going to want you the
next year and then no one else is going
to want to give you big money that's the
risk you assume for that one year payday
but it's a pretty good payday yes year
two year two you've got them backed into
a corner you've got them over a barrel
you've got them under a bill you've got
them in the that's where that's nice
with the cowboys
that's where it becomes yeah if if the
team
really wants the guy right if not for
washington they were just content to say
you're right we'll pay kirk cousins one
more year and then let him walk away but
if you really want the guy you have all
the leverage then because
you can say i'll go year to year for one
more year and next year i'll be a free
agent because you're not going to give
me a 44 raise over my second franchise
tag it becomes astronomical it's it's
cost prohibitive at that point so
bad for the player of the first year
great for the player of the second year
that's all you need to know josh and the
point is it never should get to that if
the bills know he's the guy yes once you
know he's the guy that's the lesson the
cowboys learned the hard way once you
know he's the guy it's only going to get
more expensive the longer you wait yeah
well i mean to me the big thing is and
listen i'm a little biased towards this
talk a little bit i don't like the
franchise tag i mean of course not i
mean yes and your points are all real
i'm not trying to deny any of that
quarterbacks can get away with it a
little bit more than other positions out
on the football field you know they
don't have to take on as much risk
because of the rules like we've always
talked about the way quarterbacks are
protected this day and age you know
that's why we don't even need three
quarterbacks on a roster nearly as much
anymore it's because of that aspect we
don't see them dropping or getting hurt
uh quite the same way so it is a little
easier for the quarterback to survive
that especially a really good one but
you know for the other guys again it's
just it's such a brutal sport and you
only got like
a short period of time to really strike
it rich and really take advantage of all
your talents to you know accumulate
wealth that could take a care yes of
your family for generations and do
things like that you know and the big
thing is like i said i mean the average
nfl career is three years i mean so you
only have that that short period of time
and and to me it's for the other
positions that's scary and i wish they
could find you know something for those
guys you know we've talked about this a
lot hey you're one of the best in the
world of what you do but we're not going
to give you any security yet you know
we're going to give you a lump sum and
make you prove it to us one more year
and take tremendous risk hope you don't
tear your acl or blow out your shoulder
or do something like that and that's
where i i hate it and of course i'm a
guy that came from being high tendered
and got really badly hurt and
never got a chance to really get back to
the negotiating table quite the way i
wanted to at least
yeah it's unfortunate and players can
hate it agents can hate it but it's
never
going away because the league negotiated
for it back in 1993 and even if the
league would put it on the table yeah in
cba talks i think what the league would
want for it
would be so much that the nflpa would
never agree to that ask from the league
and
and and again
we may not go through this issue because
i think everybody signed either their
franchise tender or a long-term contract
i don't think there's anybody there
there are guys out there who signed a
one-year tender who could still do a
long-term deal but they're not holding
out they're not not under contract but
the thing to remember if the franchise
tag is used on a player the player has a
lot of rights under the cba we learned
that with le'veon bell there are a lot
of things you can do you don't have to
show up you can show up just before the
start of the regular season and get your
full pay you can sit out a full year and
become a free agent the next year
although it didn't work out incredibly
well for le'veon bell over the long haul
right those are other devices available
fans get mad and teams get mad that was
the one thing that upset me about the
way the steelers handled le'veon bell
the things he was doing given his rights
under the cba because they activated the
franchise tag they were miffed at him
hey steelers you're the ones that lit
this fuse you're the ones that use the
franchise tag so it's good to see that
players in recent years have been
willing yes to say wait a minute you're
going to activate a device that keeps me
off the market because that's ultimately
what it is right i'm going to do things
under the cba that i have in my power to
apply leverage to you yeah so
for josh allen bottom line is you should
have a deal before it even gets to the
point of the franchise
but you and i agree for quarterbacks
especially because the injury risk is
lower even for a guy like josh allen who
moves around yeah you get tagged you get
tagged you you've unlocked step one
to
potentially getting either a huge
contract or getting to pick your next
team if you decide you want to move on
yeah that that's exactly right that is i
mean let me ask you this do you think
there's any way this ever gets tweaked
in some way you know again too because
there are teams to your point where
you know there's these are players they
want to keep at times they want to keep
them you know they can't balance the
checkbook whatever else the guy's asking
for a lot of money you know so they
franchise tag them just to kind of you
know push the conversation down the road
but then you know like you always talk
about they get through that year healthy
and then now it's the second year of the
franchise tag and it became a way more
expensive do you think there's ever a
day in the age where they come up with
like
kind of like the the nba rule where it's
like you're you're
you're a superstar here and you know
instead of the franchise tag i wish they
could come up with some formula for a
guy and be like
your your contract doesn't count dollar
for dollar it's it's 80 cents to the
dollar we've franchise tagged you that
which means if we gave you a 100 million
dollar contract it really only means it
counts 80 million against the salary cap
you know what i'm saying do you think
we'll ever get that type of type of
thing
probably not because the salary cap is
going to explode so much over the course
of the next decade that teams there
won't be enough teams looking for relief
from the way the salary cap is
structured yeah this year has been an
aberration because of the pandemic and
you've got teams scrambling to get under
the cap but it really wasn't that many
there were still a lot of teams that had
cap
huge margins that they had money
available to burn this year i think as
we get more and more cap dollars it's
going to be
less and less imperative that that they
find a way to make it all work teams
will use that
as a way to negotiate with one given
player at one given time to get that
player to take less right but i think
grand scheme of things there's gonna be
so much money flowing into the
marketplace and into the salary cap
formulas for the teams in the coming
years that it just won't be an issue and
unfortunately the franchise tag like i
said it's never going away and the best
players pay the price but there is a way
to play the game and especially at the
quarterback position if you have to do
it you can play the game and you can win
it's just wrong played the game he won
it one way yeah back press caught one in
a different way yeah but but the
quarterbacks are two for two under the
franchise tag over the past five years
yeah right yeah i mean they definitely
are and but but it for me it is again
it's wrong
it's wrong for for everybody else
especially every other position the
sport's just too brutal brutal physical
everything about it you're assuming all
the risk and like we said a lot of like
again you're taking away the advantage
of a guy's number one skill in life to
be re to really be able to capitalize
off that and i know life's not fair to
everybody and everything like that i get
that but
that's where i don't like it and then of
course you know there's the owners who
are just going to continue to make more
and more money and the league's going to
make more and more money and all those
type of things and they're just going to
keep going and going and going and we
know how great the nfl is but yeah i
just uh as a player that that franchise
tag always bothered me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports